[Music]
hello everyone
at the end of the previous lecture i had
mentioned that we would be going
from this version of the equation that
we had derived
uh which was
written in terms of the x y coordinate
system or refer to the x y coordinate
system
to a coordinate system which was along
the periphery
so we had this s n coordinate system
in this lecture we are actually going to
derive an important relation
which is going to enable us to go from
uh to make that transformation now
specifically
uh our first objective here is to
uh convert this uh
derivatives terms this del del x del del
y
present here as well as present here uh
into derivatives with respect to
s and n so we want to convert del del x
and del del y
to two terms involving del del s
and del del n that's our first objective
uh please note that at the end of such a
step
we would still be left with terms
involving this
nx ny as well as this mx my
so at the very first shot we are not
going to make the entire transformation
we are going to do it step by step
so the first objective will try to
realize so uh
in this lecture what we are going to do
is
try to obtain this relationship between
the derivative terms
so uh what i'll do is i'll just
just copy this diagram
to the next stage to the next page
and consider
our considered a
a unit outward normal which would be
like this
okay maybe i can just bring it down a
little bit
okay so
this i had i believe referred to as
n hat up now just to keep things
a little bit more systematic what i will
do is i refer to this
as en hat okay so that
it is absolutely clear that this is
indeed
the unit outward normal okay
uh now
uh what we are going to do
here is to uh there can be
a different ways of of obtaining this
relationship between the derivatives
but uh we'll try to do it in uh as
easy a way as possible and for that what
we'll note first of all
is that this n hat this is
this is
let me see this is referred to the
or this is inclined to the x axis at an
angle
theta okay now please note
that uh i have taken it like this i
might as well
have uh taken it here or here or here
it would make no difference okay for
example if i just go back to the
previous slide
you see that it was it was present here
okay so
uh so i mean it's absolutely the same
thing so so
let me let me just get back to this
thing okay so instead of doing it here
i can take it very much here
okay and
just convert that into green
my x axis is like this
and my y axis is like this
so as i was saying this e n hat
this is inclined to my
x-axis by this angle theta and that will
be the starting point
of our derivations so
what i'll say is that e-n-hat
that is basically
cos theta i hat
plus sine theta
j hat and this you note is perfectly
equivalent
to n x i hat plus n y
j hat
next i will consider another unit vector
which is the e s vector
so this e s vector please note uh
it will have to be oriented in this
fashion
[Music]
okay um
sorry about that now let me get back to
the appropriate page
all right so
as i was mentioning
my es vector has to be oriented in this
fashion
now you will notice that there is a
little bit of a discrepancy
in the way that i have denoted my es
vector
and the orientation of the s that i have
drawn here
in fact this particular orientation of
the s that's a little bit
problematic i should have done it this
fashion
let me correct that
the reason is
you see our x y coordinate system
that is oriented uh in a slightly
different fashion
uh compared to what is our
usual practice so usually what we do
is to orient our x y axis
in this fashion
so that if you have a contour
which is perhaps like this somewhat like
this
and you consider
you consider a little element over here
you would so that's the
that's the convention that we follow
that we that we drag this contour
in the anticlockwise sense so we would
write this as s here and this as n
here okay so you please note
that whatever the sense
of this tracking is present for this
contour
with respect to this setup of the
coordinate system x
y uh which is our usual practice
it is the same kind of system that we
are following here
okay so for example if you flip this
entire diagram vertically then
our x would still be oriented like this
or y would go
up and then the orientation of e and n
and e s that would be matching with what
we have present here
okay so this is uh a little something uh
which is
rather important and we should which we
should keep in mind now
now given the fact that we have uh we
have
set up our our vectors uh in this
fashion as well as our coordinate axis
uh what would be the representation of e
s hat this unit vector along the contour
as we track it
in this kind of a fashion okay so
uh so let us just zoom into this
diagram a little bit and note
that if our es is like this
and our en is like this
where this is the angle of inclination
theta
then this is
90 degree minus theta this is
theta and this
this orientation would be 90 degree
minus theta
so let me represent that by this double
arch
or double arc
so that this
es vector that would be written
as minus
sine theta i hat
plus cos theta
j hat please note that this minus here
is extremely extremely important okay
because this cos theta this sine theta
they are
by themselves so if you are considering
uh so this theta is an accurate angle
here
so these are all positive quantities but
in order to have the correct
representation of e s vector
we really do not need to write this out
with a minus sign and that is that is
really really important
uh that actually makes the difference uh
so if you consider here i mean if you if
you consider the minus here and the
positive
things here uh whether you take the
positive things here or the negative
things here that actually makes the
difference
between whether you are taking this as a
unit outward normal
or the unit inward normal okay so for
example
if you took that uh as minus cos theta
and minus sine theta
that would represent the unit inward
normal okay and correspondingly for the
es it will
represent the opposite orientation so it
really does make a difference
now because we have this correspondence
between the cos theta and the nx
the sine theta and the ny what we can
write here
is that this is equal to
minus so sine theta corresponds to n y
so this is
minus n y i hat plus
n x j hat this is very important
okay now uh remember that our objective
here
is to obtain a relationship between the
del del x del del y
with the del del s del del n
how can we do that so uh we'll follow a
simple strategy
of considering a general gradient
okay we'll consider a general gradient
uh and we'll write it in two different
fashions
uh so first of all you considered
the gradient of some generic entity
phi that's a scalar entity
and in the x y coordinate system that
would be written as del del
x i hat sorry about that
del phi del x i hat plus del
phi del y j hat
again this grad phi
that can be written with respect to the
s
n coordinate system as del phi
del s i hat plus
sorry ah this should be
e s hat now because we are referring to
the s n coordinate system
plus del phi del n
e n hat now
because our objective is to make some
connection between these two
and please note that these two things
they are exactly the same physical
entity as far as the physical meaning of
this grad of the five scalar quantities
entities involved they represent the
same thing so this graphite here is
absolutely the same thing as this
graphite
so these are just the different
components written with respect to the
different coordinate systems of choice
okay
but physically they mean the same thing
which is why we can draw the connection
between
them now because we have already
obtained this e s
hat in terms of the i and j let us write
that down
and also write the e n hat in terms of
the i and j
and let's compare these two things so
this is del phi del s
e s is minus n y
i hat plus n x j hat
and this will be del phi
del n or e n hat is
simply n x i hat plus
n y j hat
so what i'll do is i'll just plug these
two things together
so this is del phi
del s uh
with a minus n y
plus del phi
del n nx
that's the coefficient of i hat
and then i have
del pi del s
and x plus
from here i have this del by del n n y
del phi del n n y
so let me just adjust this entire thing
so i'll have a little more space
[Music]
okay so this is the coefficient
of j hat so all that i have to do is
compare this del by del x
which is the coefficient of i hat here
with the coefficient of i hat here
and this del phi del y which is the
coefficient of j hat here
with the coefficient of j hat which is
this so
if i so let me not go to the next page
let me just complete it here
so if i compare this here with
this entire thing
what i will obtain is del del x
that is equivalent to
minus n y del del
s plus n
x del del n
similarly del del y
that is equivalent to
n x del del
s plus n y
del del n so these are the two relations
uh which was our objective uh which we
wanted to find out
okay so we can go back to our uh
these relations and replace this del del
x del del y
with the with the relations that we have
just obtained
and uh and proceed a step closer towards
the conversion of that entire equation
with respect to this sn
coordinate system and that will do in
the next lecture
thank you very much